[Musique]
on entend souvent dire que les étudiants
devraient se concentrer sur leurs études
au lieu de faire des grèves ou des
marches pour le climat au contraire
aujourd'hui nous voulons vous montrer
que les étudiants ont tout intérêt à se
saisir des questions écologiques
mais avant de parler du rôle des
étudiants il nous paraît indispensable
de rappeler quelques faits pour rappeler
l'ampleur des enjeux auxquels nous
faisons face et l'urgence dans laquelle
nous nous trouvons nous sommes tous
collectivement depuis des années sur une
trajectoire qui nous mène droit à la
catastrophe
malgré 25 années de négociations
internationales sur le climat
nos émissions de co2 loin de diminuer
continue à augmenter et ne montre aucun
signe de ralentissement
l'accord de paris pourtant ratifiée par
5 95 pays et non seulement pas respectée
pour le moment mais ne permet pas de
rester sous la fameuse limite des 2
degrés de réchauffement climatique en
fait la trajectoire business as usual
que nous poursuivons pour le moment nous
ferait même atteindre les +4 degrés
d'ici la fin du siècle
cette courbe illustrant noir la
trajectoire que devrait suivre nos
émissions de carbone
elle démontre bien l'ampleur de l'effort
que nous avons à accomplir mais tout
simplement colossal
à moins d'un arrêt total de nos
économies dès demain il est désormais
certain que le réchauffement climatique
dépassera les 1,5 degrés et plus les
années passent plus notre marge de
manoeuvre s'amenuisent ce dérèglement
climatique aura des conséquences
dramatiques
nous serons tous que confirmer notre
génération la première aussi en france
ce graphique représente les vagues de
chaleur que notre pays a connus jusqu'en
2015 sont classés selon leur durée et
leur température
la taille des cercles représente le
nombre de décès liés aux canicules et
voilà la carte
projection de météo france pour la fin
du siècle si nous restons sur la même
trajectoire
les vagues de chaleur seront beaucoup
plus longues plus chaudes et plus mortel
que celle que nous avons connue
jusque-là et malheureusement nous ne
seront pas impactés que par la chaleur
les dérèglements des cycles de l'eau co
seront davantage de cyclones ou de crues
de sécheresse l'effondrement de la
biodiversité mettra en péril l'ensemble
de nos systèmes agricoles et
alimentaires provoquant des famines des
guerres des migrations
la banque mondiale estime ainsi à 250
millions le nombre de réfugiés
climatiques
nous pourrions connaître d'ici la fin du
siècle la réalité c'est que nous n'avons
plus le temps de ratifier les traités
les perturbations sont déjà là quand on
regarde les feux dévastateurs qui ont eu
lieu cette année en australie ou en
amazonie quand on sait que la biomasse
en insectes à 10 minutes de 76% en
europe en 27 ans nous voyons déjà les
prémices de crise écologique toujours
plus grave si les mesures prises par les
états sont sans aucun doute décevante
on peut difficilement dire que les
acteurs privés sont davantage à la
hauteur alors que les industriels et les
transporteurs sont les premiers
concernés par la nécessité d'une
réduction drastique de leurs émissions
une observons aucun branle bas
selon eux cela ne semble pas inquiéter
grand monde à l'image d'air france qui
depuis quelques semaines affiche avec
fierté la possibilité de prendre encore
plus l'avion puisque tout peut être
compensé en plantant des arbres
quand on parle de réduction drastique
des émissions
il s'agit bien d'arrêter d'émettre ils
n'ont pas de compenser la compensation
carbone telle qu'elle est envisagée
aujourd'hui par les entreprises est une
solution illusoire
du côté de l'agriculture qui représente
en france 17% des émissions de gaz à
effet de serre
le peu de moyens alloués à la recherche
pour des solutions alternatives aux
usages conventionnelle est le reflet
d'une absence de réelle prise de
conscience
malgré la mini la multiplication des
annonces ambitieuse le monde de la
finance n'est pas non plus à la hauteur
comment croire un changement profond
quand on sait qu'un fonds
d'investissement socialement responsable
continue de financer des énergies
fossiles et reste à 90 % basée sur le
même univers d'investissement les camps
les grandes entreprises restent bloqués
dans une quête
profites incapable de remettre en
question leur modèle économique et de
changer de paradigme bien souvent
davantage d'argent est utilisé à des
fins de communication car la mise en
place de solutions réelles
alors face à ce constat difficile la
tentation pourrait être grande de
s'aider soi la peur en refusant de
regarder la réalité en face et en
continuant comme si de rien n'était soit
au désespoir en se disant que tout est
déjà perdue et puis qu'on verra bien
nous pourrions tout aussi bien penser
que ce sont des enjeux qui se jouent
dans les hautes sphères et qu'il nous
faut avant tout étudier puis faire
carrière et que quand nous atteindrons
des postes à responsabilité nous
pourrons commencer à agir
ce n'est pas le choix que nous avons
fait et ce n'est pas le choc nous
faisons la réalité c'est que nous
n'avons plus le temps d'attendre pour
agir je crois qu'il est de notre devoir
de tout mettre en oeuvre pour que ces
constats ne soit pas une fatalité
en tant qu'étudiants et en tant que
jeunes nous avons de réelles marges de
manoeuvre pour provoquer les changements
profonds qui sont nécessaires ce
problème c'est aussi et c'est surtout le
nôtre il faut nous en saisir si les
petits pas à l'échelle individuelle
peuvent sembler juste voir face à manger
à l'enjeu on nous réunissons nous
pouvons beaucoup c'est l'objet de
l'initiative que nous partons depuis un
an et demi vous l'avez peut-être vu
peut-être signé nous sommes plus de
trente deux mille étudiants avoir
exprimé nos revendications
dans le manifeste étudiants pour un
réveil écologique ce texte exprime notre
frustration malgré d'une part notre
conscience aiguë de la crise écologique
en cours et d'autre part notre très
forte volonté de l'enrayer au plus vite
les structures économiques existantes
elles nous permettent pas de nous
engager pleinement dans cette voie c'est
pourquoi nous nous disons nous disons
prêt à questionner notre zone de confort
pour que changent ce modèle économique
dans lequel nous ne croyons plus en
particulier nous nous engageons à
choisir un employeur en fonction de son
projet écologique
ce texte a eu un écho insoupçonnées
auprès des dirigeants d'entreprise
depuis plus d'un an nous arpentons les
tours à la défense pour leur porter
notre message si leur entreprise ne
change pas radicalement leurs activités
pour rester dans le cadre des limites
planétaires
elles seront de plus en plus de mal à
recruter
les leçons à tirer de ces rencontres
sont nombreuses à travers quelques
histoires nous avons tenté de les
résumer en trois points puis de voir
quelles sont les demandes que nous
pouvons voir dès le premier point c'est
que nous sortons souvent désabusés de
ces rencontres
désabusé tant l'ampleur de la tâche à
accomplir est grande dans l'inertie au
sein des grands groupes est importante
étant la question n'est pas traitée à la
hauteur de l'enjeu
que dire de ce pdg d'un grand groupe
cimentier qui nous annonce fièrement
avoir installé des ruches sur le toit de
ses usines et qui nous en parle
longuement alors même que le bilan
carbone de son entreprise s'élève à
plusieurs millions de tonnes de co2 ou
de ce cabinet de conseil qui se targue
d'avoir enlevé les tweets en plastique à
la machine à café
trop souvent le développement durable se
cantonne à des petits gestes impact
extrêmement limité dans d'autres cas il
sert d'excusé pour développer de
nouvelles offres sans rien changer à
celles qui existent déjà
on est heureux d'apprendre que les
constructeurs automobiles développent de
plus en plus de véhicules électriques
mais si par ailleurs il vend des
voitures toujours plus grosses qui
ressemblent davantage à des tanks et des
voitures où est la cohérence en 2010
l'impact négatif lié à la vente des suv
a été cinq fois plus important que
l'impact positif lié à la vente des
véhicules électriques et la faute repose
autant voire davantage sur le
constructeur que sur le consommateur
or nous voyons les stratégies marketing
agressive mise en place pour pousser à
l'achat de ces véhicules
deuxième point que nous rend compte que
nous retenons ceci rend compte c'est que
nous sommes régulièrement effaré par le
manque de connaissance de certains
dirigeants sur les problématiques et les
ordres de grandeur obnubilé par les
résultats financiers la tête dans le
guidon
beaucoup ont du mal à prendre de la
hauteur pour comprendre vraiment les
mécanismes à l'oeuvre et la complexité
de la situation dans laquelle nous nous
trouvons une administratrice d'un grand
groupe a par exemple affirmé sans
sourciller que ma demande de moins
prendre l'avion pour privilégier des
vidéoconférences était paradoxal en
effet qui dit plus de vidéos dit plus
d'ordinateurs et plus de données donc
plus de pollution
je vaux mieux dit elle parfois se
déplacer en personne il avait sans doute
échappé qu'il ya environ un facteur 10
milles entre les émissions d'un vol et
celle dans l'appel d'une heure sur skype
et puis quand bien même les dirigeants
ce serait un tant soit peu renseigné sur
la question les transformations
effectuées sont tellement profonde
il remet totalement en cause leur
carrière qu'il leur est extrêmement
difficile de changer de paradigme
sans vouloir attiser un conflit
générationnel
je crois que nous pouvons rosé dès
aujourd'hui à porter un regard neuf et
remettre en question un certain nombre
de pratiques que l'on voudrait nous
imposer
enfin le dernier point sur lequel nous
nous attarderons c'est qu'à travers ces
rencontres nous avons compris que nous
ne devons pas négliger l'impact que nous
pouvons avoir nous sommes de plus en
plus nombreux au sein de notre
génération à aspirer un changement de
notre modèle économique
aujourd'hui le pragmatisme n'est plus du
côté du business as usual
il a changé de camp sur une planète en
plein bouleversement la seule option
rationnelle et d'aspirer et de
participer à changer le monde
nous sommes en train de gagner la
bataille des idées n'ayons pas peur de
porter nos revendications ou que nous
soyons et en particulier dans notre
sphère professionnelle
je crois que cela peut aujourd'hui
davantage nous ouvrir des portes que de
nous enfermer dans le cas contraire si
ce n'était pas la bonne porte
alors maintenant que faire de toutes ces
rencontres nous distinguons avec plus de
clarté quelques demandes que nous
pouvons pureté en urgence tout d'abord
pour ne pas reproduire les erreurs
commises et apporter des solutions à la
hauteur de l'enjeu
nous vous devons nous former apprendre à
réfléchir de façon transversale et
complexe la question de l'urgence
écologique n'est pas que scientifiques
économiques ou sociales elle est un tout
que tout le monde devrait pouvoir
appréhender pour apporter des réponses
intégralement cohérente
il est donc indispensable que nos
formations évoluent et qu'elle intègre
les enjeux de transition dans leur
enseignement et ce dans les troncs
communs en menant de cursus spécifique
performant c'est la condition sine qua
none pour permettre à chacun d'inventer
l'avenir en toute connaissance de cause
là aussi nous avons un rôle à jouer
le collectif que nous représentons
invite les étudiants à se mobiliser dans
leurs écoles pour faire évoluer les
enseignements notre site regroupe des
clés des retours d'expérience nous avons
eu nous y allons aussi avec des
institutions
comme le ministère de l'enseignement
supérieur et la recherche pour appeler à
une évolution au plus vite de
l'information si ce système éducatif
doit évoluer le monde du travail aussi
former les dirigeants et les cadres aux
questions environnementales est une
nécessité mais on ne peut pas se
contenter de cela une entreprise
sérieuse sur les questions écologiques
inclurait bien sûr la problématique au
coeur de son système financier
aujourd'hui les rémunérations des
dirigeants sont majoritairement indexés
sur les cours de l'action cela conduit
certaines entreprises comme total a
dépensé huit fois dans le budget de r&d
au rachat d'actions pour faire monter
les cours et ainsi faire bénéficier les
dirigeants de plus de primes et
favoriser les actionnaires ce type de
politique court termiste marqueur s'il
en est puis dogme de la maximisation des
profits est très certainement
responsable de la faiblesse et de la
lenteur de la transformation des
entreprises pour dépasser cette logique
il est également indispensable que la
comptabilité évolué et ne prennent plus
seulement en compte les bénéfices
financiers mais aussi sociaux et
environnementaux
une entreprise sérieuse sur les
questions écologiques devraient
connaître connaître précisément son
impact sur les écosystèmes et le climat
et mettre en oeuvre des stratégies
crédibles pour les réduire
l'implémentation de ces stratégies
devraient être partie intégrante des
critères de réussite d'un projet être
exploité dans l'ensemble des processus
opérationnels
le département des filiales de
l'entreprise ces stratégies ne devrait
pas reposer sur des technologies dont le
déploiement est incertain mais bien sûr
des démarches de sobriété
ce qui n'est pas antinomique avec la
prospérité l'entreprise se devrait aussi
d'être cohérente avec l'ensemble de ses
parties prenantes en mettant un terme à
certaines activités de lobbying
industriel qui nuisent à la mise en
place de lois ambitieuses et en ayant
des exigences environnementales et
sociales fortes envers leurs
fournisseurs et sous traitants
enfin une entreprise sérieuse sur les
questions écologiques adapterait ses
activités pour apporter une utilité
réelle à la société cette utilité serait
fondé sur un besoin existant et pérenne
et non pas sur la création d'un besoin
temporaire et court termiste avons nous
réellement besoin d'un énième hamburger
en
or moins cher encore plus emballé est
encore trop avons-nous vraiment besoin
de cette montre connectés qui nous
permettent de démarrer la cuisson des
pâtes tout en lançant l'aspirateur
autonome
le tout depuis notre train alimentées en
5 j nous voulons travailler pour des
entreprises pour lesquels l'utilité et
la raison d'être et qui définissent
comme objectif premier la création d'un
pacte social et environnemental positif
évidemment aujourd'hui aucun grand
groupe ne peut se targuer de répondre
parfaitement aux critères que nous
venons énoncés qui sont pourtant plus
issus du bon sens que de l'utopie ces
demandes que nous portons je nous invite
à les avoir en tête lors de nos choix
d'emplois personnellement quand je suis
arrivé dans mon école d'ingénieurs j'ai
été frappé par le peu de diversité les
entreprises que nous avons l'occasion de
rencontrer tout nous promettent une
belle carrière
l'accès à des postes à responsabilités
des salaires impressionnant cela ne
m'attire pas du tout au contraire
à quoi bon gagner ainsi aux salaires si
nous détruisons notre futur par notre
travail quotidien
nous avons une chance immense celle de
ne pas être ramolli par la force des
habitudes
profitons-en pour nous tourner vers les
employeurs chez qui nous pourrons mettre
à profit notre capacit notre capacité
notre imagination au service de
l'intérêt général et de la transition
écologique cette transition ne pourra
pas se faire sans une réflexion
approfondie sur la liberté la mesure de
notre liberté d'homme sur terre sur ce
que signifie le confort vis-à-vis de
l'abondance et de l'excès et sur ce que
peut être le bonheur tant que la société
ne travaillera pas au bien être commun
donc nous avons nous devons discuter de
là où nous voulons aller
nous devons imaginer ce que nous voulons
construire le dialogue n'est pas la voie
la plus simple mais c'est la seule qui
permette à chacun de prendre part à
cette construction
nous devons et nous pouvons transformer
le rapport que nous avons avec notre
environnement
en tant que jeune c'est une
responsabilité que nous avons envers
notre futur en tant que travailleur
c'est une responsabilité que nous avons
envers le modèle social qui nous entoure
en tant qu'être humain c'est une
responsabilité que nous avons envers le
système terre de conclure on simplement
on vous invite dans tous à nous
rejoindre dans ce combat pour notre
planète pour notre futur pour l'humanité
comme nous l'avons vu nous avons un
certain nombre de barrières à faire
tomber mais c'est également une
opportunité immense qui s'ouvre à nous
dirigeants d'entreprise soyez des guides
éclairés d'une destination ambitieuse
citoyens soyons l'énergie nécessaire
pour réparer une transformation profonde
capable de faire face à l'urgence
étudiants construisons un système sobre
circulaire à l'impact positif qui prenne
en compte l'ensemble de l'humanité et
permettent à la terre de recouvrir ses
capacités et sa richesse construisons
notre monde un monde résilient
[Applaudissements]
[Musique]